at what point did you make the decision
to make the president
a tv star um
a couple years around when donald trump
was becoming president um
you know we wanted the movie to be
reflective of times and i think like
there's not a lot of movies that have
been made in the last few years that i
think really
try to let the audience know that the
people who made the movie live
in the same world as them and experience
the same culture as them
so it was hard because we kept trying to
think like what would be good for our
movie for the president to be we have a
president character
and it was kind of a moving target
wherever we thought of something crazy
something crazier would happen and so we
were like oh
oh and then we had this idea where the
president
in the film is bob owen kirk and he
played the president on a successful tv
show for years
and then was nominated as the president
of america
which we thought was kind of crazy and
then the exact same thing just happened
in ukraine
like one week ago and
it's a moving target just when you think
you've outdone reality reality comes and
does something crazier than what you
thought of no it's not we're amazing we
are amazing
is so nuts now and like
so you said you worked with stormy
daniels
i did work not in a porno film
did you not know this just say it like
that stormy daniels is in uh
knock she's in both knocked up and the
40 year old virgin
um we
first of all i am learning so much
very early in our careers we realized
like if you ever need someone to be
naked in a movie you should hire a porn
star because it's the easiest thing they
did that week
and they're just
in general there it's not a situation
where you're like convincing a
mainstream actress to get naked instead
you're taking a port actress and putting
her in a mainstream movie and she
doesn't have to put anything
in her and so she's thrilled and so
stormy
stripper scenes in these films and
stormy played a stripper in the
in those films were you considering her
for last time she was for a while going
to be
so i i go way back uh stormy
but she didn't tell you all the stories
then yes then she did tell us that she
had had a relationship with donald trump
and at the time when a porn star tells
you they have sex with donald trump it's
the least interesting thing you had
heard that
uh day was the most expected information
you could ever
expect to hear and literally was not
interesting to me i was like oh yeah
great a porn started sex with don't
like yeah that's exactly what i would
expect to happen and then years later it
became pretty relevant information
that i was just stuck there with and i
was like do i say something i was like i
don't think i should say something i
think it's a good place to
say something believe you played it
right seth i played my card you know in
general i played my cards as well
there was a shot that i think you were
on location in new york and uh
so this is without this is without the
special effects
so this is uh doctor strange is that the
what do you call energy wrong about to
take off
oh you're taking yeah oh that's that's
me about to fly oh okay he's about to
fly
anywhere for some reason the way these
things do that image
just captured people's imaginations so
they've taken
benedict's australia put them in
different places so here's benedict on a
zip wire
he's also very sporty there he is
[Laughter]
he's also cultured music is his life
very good at the ice skating ladies and
gentlemen
that was like it looks like it's real
that looks like a donald trump move
by the way we're sorry
we're so
and i think a lot of people here don't
realize that this is a real thing i mean
president trump has set up a space force
yeah they
um well it's almost like parallel
development too because
they released the pictures of their new
uniforms and then we released the
pictures of our new uniforms
and they released their their they
unfurled their flag
in the white house recently and it's and
it's so
funny how certain aspects mirror each
other
and and how you know there's there's
differentiation for sure
but i mean it's as if they're not taking
it that seriously
i mean when you look at their logo they
didn't try that hard
i mean essentially that is star trek
yeah it's pretty close and incidentally
the people who are in charge of space
force have been
really uh really nice about it have had
a great sense of humor about our show
haven't been thin skinned at all and uh
so they seem to be fans so far which is
nice
but the actual general now he he didn't
think you should play him did he
no apparently he thought bruce willis
would have been a better choice
i i read something where he said about
your hair was too shaggy and i was like
what does he mean by that
and then i saw him
bruce willis or jeff bezos could have
played him those are his dream
team this this is a picture of johnny
depp
as donald trump what
isn't that amazing wow what was that for
john oh my god
that was just for me you wanted to know
what it felt like to be that awesome
weekend i never thought i wanted to kill
johnny
i can only say that you should
how did it come up did you already do a
donald trump impression
no no no no and i had no idea if i could
or not i
still don't but i i mean this guy you
know adam mckay
who i i admire greatly and who's one of
the funniest humans alive
we had a meeting we were sitting there
talking he said how would you like to
how would you like to do a feature film
in four days and i went
i like that idea and then he said how
would you like to play donald trump
and i loved that idea
i didn't care if i knew if i was capable
or not you know
i wanted to try so yeah so i
i i did my bit as donald trump
you don't want to be donald trump
because
he's the way he speaks is very specific
yeah
were you telling all the mexicans to get
offset
i told them to build me that wall
i want a sensational wall on a
fabulous wall
i don't remember what the question was
but it doesn't matter because i'm not
going to answer it anyway
[Applause]
[Music]
have you met the trump at all on things
jennifer i haven't
no i was at a concert that i heard he
was
attending so i had my full security like
i was like
fine donald trump because i was just i
was adamant on
um finding him and then making a video
of me going
hey trump [__] you
i wouldn't rest until it was found i
think he knew i was looking for him
[Music]